Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Disabender Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das Ersgespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, alles in Ordnung, Frau Doktor.
Ok, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißt Sie denn?
Ja, mein Name ist Anna Röhrä.
Frau Röhrä, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestabieren?
Ja, A, Doppel N, A und R, O, O, O, A, R, E.
Ok, Frau Röhrä, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 34, Frau Doktor.
Ok, wann ist Sie genau geboren?
24.09.1990
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,71 Meter groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
72 kg.
Ok, wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin?
Frau Graf.
WF Ende oder?
Ja, WF. G, R, A, WF.
Danke schön. Vielen Dank für diese Information, Frau Röhrä. Und was für Sie heute so uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Rötung bemerkt im Bereich des rechten Kniegelenks.
Ich habe Rötung und fühle mich müde.
Ich fühle mich erschöpft, kann ich sagen.
Seit 4 Tagen habe ich Rötung bemerkt.
Auf der äußeren Seite im Bereich des rechten Kniegelenks.
Ok, haben Sie nur eine Rötung?
Ja, eine Rötung habe ich bemerkt.
Ok, wie groß ist diese Rötung?
Das ist 4 cm groß.
Wie runde ist die Rötung.
Mitte ist hellrot und Rande dunkelrot.
Ok, Rande dunkelrot.
Denken Sie, hat sich diese Rötung vergrößert?
Nein, seit 4 Tagen das gleiche.
Wissen Sie, ob es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Rötung gibt?
Vor 5 Tagen habe ich im Wald gewandert.
Vor 5 Tagen?
Ja, vor 5 Tagen.
Ich hatte Schmerzen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, beim Laufen im rechten Kniegelenks.
Aber ich habe kein Insekt bemerkt.
Nach dem Schmerzen hatte ich Rötung bemerkt.
Ok, aber Sie haben keine Insekten bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe nicht gesehen.
Nur habe ich Schmerzen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dann Rötung habe ich bemerkt.
Ok, haben Sie Schmerzen? Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Ich fühle mich abgeschlagen und fieberig.
Alle Gelenke sind Schmerzhaft.
Ich habe Gelenkschmerzen in allen Gelenken.
Ich fühle mich fieberig.
Hat Sie Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen?
Ja, heute Morgen. Meine Körpertemperatur war 37,9.
Ich habe nur heute gemessen und es war 37,9.
Wie stark sind Ihre Kopfschmerzen?
Nicht schlimm, aber ich fühle mich seit 3 Tagen Kopfschmerzen.
Ich fühle mich nicht gut, Frau Doktor.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ich habe im Kopf Schmerzen.
Ich fühle mich auch im Nacken und Schulter.
Könnten Sie Ihren Nacken vorbeugen?
Ja, ich kann vorbeugen, aber ein bisschen Schmerzhaft.
Ich habe im Nacken Schmerzen.
Fühlen Sie sich an der Nackenstäffigkeit?
Nein, nicht stif, aber Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen ein Übel?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Hatten Sie Erbrechen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, aber Schutelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß hatte ich gestern Abend, aber Schutelfrost hatte ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewöhnlich-Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Nein, ich bin immer gleich.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Heute ist es nicht gut. Ich möchte heute nicht essen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, wegen vieler Schlagenheit oder Abgeschlagenheit gestern Abend.
Ich könnte nicht gut schlafen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Okay, es freut mich sehr gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Umgebung jemanden mit 50 Hebechwerden?
Nein, nur habe ich.
Okay, haben Sie Hüsten?
Ich habe keine Hüsten.
Okay, oder Schnürfen oder Halsschmerzen?
Ich habe ganz viel Halsschmerzen.
Halsschmerzen habe ich auch, aber nicht genau.
Nicht besonders?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Erkrankungen bekannt?
Seit dem siebten Lebensjahr leide ich an Typ 1 Diabetes.
Okay.
Deswegen nutze ich Insulinpumpe.
Insulinpumpe?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich misse mein Blutszucker regelmäßig mit einem Blutszuckersensor, Glukossensor.
Okay, Glukossensor.
Meinen Sie eine Glukospumpe?
Ja, sie sind zusammen.
Wenn meine Glukose hoch ist, habe ich eine Nachricht von der Insulinpumpe.
Und das wird regelmäßig kontrolliert.
Okay, ist Ihr Blutszucker gut angestellt?
Ja, gut angestellt.
Okay.
Noch etwas?
Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, leider seit acht Jahren Migräne.
Migräne, okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen Migräne ein?
Manchmal nehme ich Ibuprofen, manchmal Aspirin, wenn ich Schmerz habe.
Okay, wissen Sie die Dosierung dieser Medikamente?
Manchmal nehme ich nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, kein Problem.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, vor zwölf Jahren wegen Leistenherrli wurde ich operiert.
Okay, das war komplikationlos?
Ja, ja, das sei dann.
Noch etwas?
Andere Operationen?
Nein, ich wurde operiert.
Okay, sind Sie Rafferin, Frau Rohre?
Ja, seit zehn Jahren rauche ich 15 Zigarillo.
Zigarillo?
Ja.
Was meinen Sie?
Zigarillo ist kleine Zigarette.
Kleine Zigarette?
Ja.
Kleine Zigarette, okay.
Ja, das heißt Zigarillo, ja.
Ja, ich habe das erste Mal gehört.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gerne jeden Tag ein oder zwei Gläser Wein.
Rotwein.
Okay.
Mein Freund hat mir empfohlen zu trinken, das war sehr gesund, hat mir er gesagt.
Deswegen trinke ich jeden Tag ein oder zwei Gläser Rotwein.
Okay, ich habe keine Kommentare über diese Säubchen gemacht.
Okay, hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, nein.
Okay, sehr gut, es freut mich.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ich möchte diese Frage nicht antworten.
Über Drogen.
Drogen oder Drogen?
Drogen, ja, Drogenrauchen.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Und treibst du regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich treibe regelmäßig Sport.
Ich schwimme gerne.
Zweimal pro Woche schwimme ich.
Okay, Frau Rohre, wir haben Drogenanamnese-Fragen gestellt,
weil Drogen kann ihre Beschwerden verschlichten oder einige Medikamente integrieren.
Deshalb fragen wir diese Anamnese-Fragen.
Über Drogen oder?
Über Drogen alle noch.
Das ist eine private Sache für mich, ich möchte nicht mitteilen.
Alle Informationen bleiben nur Sie und mir.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig für uns, den Datenschutz, wissen Sie?
Deshalb möchte ich diese Informationen geben.
Ja, das ist sicher, Sie haben Informationen nur zwischen uns, Sie haben gesagt, richtig?
Ja, zwischen uns.
Ich kann sagen, aber ...
Dann teile ich mit, ehrlich gesagt, brauche ich zweimal Mariana pro Woche.
Ich habe viel Stress, Frau Doktor, deswegen brauche ich zweimal Joint pro Woche.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Danke schön.
Aber das ist privat, ich bitte Sie, um mit anderen Menschen nicht zu teilen.
Das ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Ja, Sie kann sicher sein.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Friseurin, Frau Doktor.
Aber seit drei Tagen kann ich nicht arbeiten, wegen meiner Schmerzen fühle ich mich nicht gut.
Okay, und leben Sie alleine oder mit jemandem?
Sind Sie verheiratet oder haben Sie einen Partner?
Ich bin ledig und ich wohne alleine.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin ledig und habe keine Kinder.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe alle Impfungen gehabt.
Okay, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, ich war vor fünf Tagen in Frankreich. Wir haben eine Waldlaufwanderung gemacht.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Eltern sind ganz gesund, sie sind nicht alt.
Mein Vater ist 55 und meine Mutter ist 53, deswegen sind sie ganz gesund.
Okay, haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, wir sind drei Geschwister. Ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Meine kleinste Schwester hat leider Down-Syndrom.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid zu hören. Aber ist sie gesund jetzt?
Ja, sie ist nicht körperlich, aber sie ist sehr leid.
Sie ist sehr stressig für meine Mutter und für uns auch.
Okay, ich verstehe. Das ist eine sehr schwierige Situation.
Frau Rohrer, haben Sie regelmäßige Regerblutung?
Ja, meine Perioden sind regelmäßig.
Okay, wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Vor 15 Tagen.
Könnten Sie schwanger sein?
Nein, ich habe verhütet.
Okay, verhütet. Gehen Sie regelmäßig zu Ihrem Frauenarzt oder Ihrer Frau?
Ja, seit letztem Jahr habe ich meine Frau besucht.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, Ordnung hat mir gedrückt.
Okay, Frau Rohrer, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst natürlich. Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich fieberig. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Haben Sie eine Röthung? Ist das gefährlich?
Oder was ist das, Frau Doktor?
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, Frau Rohrer.
Ich weiß, dass es schwer ist.
Aber momentan gibt es keinen Grund für Sorge.
Es ist noch zu früh, um etwas Geniales zu sagen.
Ich habe eine Vermutung. Um meine Vermutung zu bestätigen, muss ich einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen und einige Laboparameter überprüfen.
Wenn alle Ergebnisse so weit vorliegen, kann ich etwas Geniales sagen.
Ich möchte Sie bitte noch ein wenig geduld haben.
Bitte warten Sie in den Untersuchungsraum. Ich werde gleich zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay, Frau Doktor. Danke Ihnen.
Ist meine Röthung ansteckend? Oder möchte ich fragen?
Nein.
Ist das gefährlich für andere Personen?
Ich denke, es ist nicht gefährlich und ansteckend.
Aber ich werde alle notwendigen Untersuchungen und Maßnahmen durchführen.
Okay, Frau Doktor. Ich danke Ihnen.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Sie haben eine neue Patientin.
Die Patientin ist Anna Röhr. Sie ist 34 Jahre alt, 1,71 Meter groß und 72 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Röhr stellte sich heute bei uns wegen einer Rötung an dem rechten Kniegelenk vor.
Der Patient berichtete, dass diese Rötung oder dieser Fleck 4 cm groß und schmerzlos ist.
Sie beschreibt den Fleck als Eritermannmigrant mit Hellezentrum und geröteter Rand.
Dieser Fleck ist vor vier Tagen nach einer Erwanderung aufgetreten.
Der Patient berichtet über Sephalgie, Immialgie und Gelenkschmerzen mit Nackenschmerzen.
Aber die Fragen nach Nacken, Polyatriarchie, die Patienten klagten über Sephalgie, Immialgie und Gelenkschmerzen.
Der Patient verwandelt die Panthenen selbst für diese Rötung ohne Besserung.
Der Patient berichtet über Fieber 37,9 Grad Celsius sowie Neusea und nächtliche Hyperlipidation.
Die Viganditivanamnese ist unerfällig bis auf in Apatens und Insomni.
Der Patient klagt über Auf und Fatigue.
Diese Rötung ist jöchelnd.
Die Anfängerkrankungen leiden sie seit 17 Jahren an Diabetes-Melotistips 2 und seit acht Jahren an Migräne.
Die Patienten nehmen bei Bedarf gegen Migräne, Ibuprofen oder Acetylsalicylusole.
Die Dosierung dieser Medikamente wird geklärt.
Der Patient verwandelt Insulin Pompe gegen Diabetes-Melotistips 2.
Die Patienten wurden vor zwölf Jahren aufgrund einer Ingenieurherniatomie durchgeführt.
Sie ist Racherin und rafft seit zehn Jahren 15 kleine Zigaretten.
Sie trinkt jeden Tag 1-2 Gläser Rotwein.
Die Patienten rufen 2 Mal pro Woche Marijuana.
Sie hat viel Stress in der Arbeit. Sie schwimmt 2 Mal pro Woche regelmäßig.
Sie arbeitet als Friseurin. Sie ist ledig und lebt allein. Sie hat keine Kinder.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft und hat keine bekannten Allergien. Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben, dass ihr Vater oder ihr Eltern gesund ist. Sie hat zwei Schwestern und eine Schwester hat Down-Syndrome.
Der Patient hat keine Insekten oder Insekten bemerkt.
Wie anstecken diese Krankheiten?
Die Anamnese kann oder kann nicht sein. Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich folgende Maßnahmen durchgeführt.
Ich werde die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Migranten vorhanden sind.
Ich würde die Patienten neurologisch untersuchen.
Alle Reflexe und Nackenstiftigkeit kontrollieren.
Welche Zeichen kontrollieren Sie?
Ich würde Burczewski und Kerninkzeichen kontrollieren.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungparameter BSG-CRP, Nieren- und Labo-Werte, Elektrolytös und auch eine Antikörpergegenberyllose bestimmen lassen.
Ich würde Blut abnehmen und ein großes Blutbild CRP-BSG bestimmen lassen.
Welche Fehler bemerken Sie in diesem Satz?
Ich würde ein großes Blutbild und ein Entzündungparameter BSG-CRP bestimmen lassen.
Sie haben zuerst nur ein großes Blutbild CRP-BSG-Lukustensal bestimmen lassen.
Subjekt, Modalwerb oder andere Werbfeld.
Ich würde einige Labo-Parameter bestimmen lassen.
Ich würde ein großes Blutbild, ein Entzündungparameter und eine Antikörpergegenberyllose bestimmen lassen.
Wenn ich unklar bin über die Berylose oder meine Verdachtstheorose, würde ich eine CT-Bestimmung machen.
Ich denke, Sie haben wieder falsche Satze gesagt.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtstheorose bestätige.
Wenn ich unklar bin, würde ich eine Verstätigung machen.
Wenn Sie falsche Verdachtstheorose bestimmen, würde ich eine CT-Bestimmung machen.
Welche Verdachtstheorose denken Sie jetzt?
Jetzt Berylose. Ich habe keine weiteren Untersuchungen.
Ich möchte keine weiteren Untersuchungen als CT oder MRT oder Röntgen durchführen.
Ich möchte meine Verdachtstheorose bestätigen.
Wenn ich eine weitere Untersuchung durchführen möchte, würde ich eine andere Untersuchung durchführen.
Welche andere Untersuchungen?
CT. Warum verhandeln Sie CT?
Um die Meningitis oder Meningoencephalitis auszuschließen.
Natürlich denke ich auch an eine Lomberponktion.
Aber das sind nicht meine ersten Untersuchungen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Dublix-Sonographie machen?
Nein. Ich habe die Patientin nicht gefragt.
Aber der Patient hat keine Taubhausgefühl, Rötung, Überwärmung oder kalte Haut.
Sie hat Rötung?
Sie hat Rötung, aber keine anderen Beschwerden.
Ich denke nicht, dass es eine Stenose oder eine PA-Folka ist.
Deshalb ist das nicht meine erste Untersuchung.
Aber wenn es eine PA-Folka ist, können wir es durchführen.
Aber nicht jetzt oder nicht zuerst.
Welche Apparativdiagnose würden Sie zuerst verhandeln?
Ich habe keine weiteren Untersuchungen.
Ich werde zuerst meine Labo-Untersuchungen warten.
Ich möchte Antikörper gegen Berliose sehen.
Dann dauert es zwei Tage.
Dauert es zwei Tage?
Ja.
Ja, echt?
Der Test dauert ungefähr zwei Tage.
Okay. Dann möchte ich eine CT durchführen.
Dann würde ich eine CT durchführen.
Ja.
Oder eine Doublexonographie.
Nein.
Ja, beide.
Welche Therapie würden Sie?
Ich werde Antibiotik machen.
Ich würde die Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Sie haben nicht die Vorhöhung oder die Medikamente.
Sie sind in gutem Allgemeinzustand.
Ich kann diese Patienten beim Unkollegentrohung bewahren.
Deshalb denke ich, dass diese Patienten die ambulanten Therapie machen können.
Aber es kann sein, dass die Meningitis gefährlich ist.
Ja, es kann sehr schnell gehen.
Es kann sehr gefährlich sein.
Und es kann eine eingeschränkte Station sein.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, Stationäre aufzunehmen.
Okay.
Ich würde eine Antibiotik-Therapie mit 90 Zyklen beginnen.
Nach zwei Tagen möchte ich die Patienten wiederholen.
Wiedersehen.
Oder wieder kontrollieren.
Dann würde ich eine Lomapunktion oder CT des Schadens veranlassen.
Aber ich empfehle den Patienten, wenn sie andere Beschwerden,
z.B. neurologische Symptome oder andere Symptome haben,
sie schnell in das Krankenhaus gehen.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Ich empfehle den Patienten, lange Hose und lange Schuhe zu tragen.
Und wenn sie eine Sekte an der Körper bemerken,
schnell ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Empfehlen Sie bei den Patienten Sekte-Übungen?
Ja, der Patient gerne Wanderung.
Deshalb kann ich diese Patienten sehr gut empfehlen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.
Bitte warten Sie auf uns.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Es handelt sich um Hanna Rohrer.
Sie ist 34 Jahre alt und 72 kg schwer.
Sie ist 1,71 Meter groß.
Die Patienten stellen sich heute bei uns
bestehende Einzelpläken am rechten Kniegelenk vor.
Wegen.
Stellt sich heute bei uns Wegen.
Wegen, ja Wegen. Unnoten.
Wegen bestehende Einzelpläken am rechten Kniegelenk vor.
Die Patienten bestätigen, dass sie vor fünf Tagen
diese Pläken nach einem langen Wandern bemerkt haben.
Die Pläne sind dunkelrot am Rund und hell in der Mitte.
Wie ein röter Ring.
Die Flasche ist 4 cm groß.
Die Patienten, die Symptome,
die Symptome würden mit Asteni, Mialgie,
Sefalgie, Polyarthralgie und Pyrexie einhergehen.
Die Frage nach Unfall, Schwerlungen,
Ukrains Blutung und Offene wurden nach Steifigkeit
und Stülpfrost würden verneint.
Die Wege hat anliegende Beschwerden früher nicht gehabt.
Die Einmalige von Bepenthenzalve hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Frage nach Säckewissen würde verneint.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf
Inappetenz und Insomnie.
Anführererkrankungen nannte sie bestehende Typ 1 Diabetes.
Sie hat seit acht Jahren bestehende Migräne.
Die Typ 1 Diabetes ist mit Insulinpumpe behandelt.
Sie nimmt Ibuprofen und Aspirin bei Bedarf ein.
Aber die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Die Frage nach Allergie wurde verneint.
Die Patienten wurden eine Laistenhernie durchgeführt.
Sie haben seit 20 Jahren Cigarillo getrunken.
Sie trinken einen Tag ein Glas Wein.
Sie konsumieren zwei Mal Joint-Provoche.
Die Anamnese teilt, dass der Vater und die Mutter gesund sind.
Sie haben ein Kind, das Down-Syndrom ist.
Sie haben einen Regelblutung.
Sie trägt regelmäßig zweimal pro Woche.
Sie arbeitet als Frisörin.
Sie leidet und wohnt alleine.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Ich gehe jeden Tag auf Leimborelius aus, da die Patienten typische Symptome dafür ausweisen.
Die Patienten leiden über Eritama Migrans.
Sie haben Pyrexie, Asthenie, Koppschmerzen, Polyarthralgie und Mealgie.
Das ist die Sprit für Leimborelius.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, die Frage nach Zekawissen wurde verneint.
Ja, aber die Patientin hat nicht Zekawissen bemerkt.
Zekawissen ist unklar.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Erisipel, meningitis und Imbetrach.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst die Patienten vitalen Parameter überwachen.
Dann würde ich die Patienten körperliche und körperliche Unbefugnisse beherrschen.
um die Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei wurde ich kleine Blutbild-Bsg-SRP und Antikörper gegen Borreliose bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT-Schadar durchführen und mögliche Hirnblutung oder Ödeme ausschließen.
Dann würde ich eine Lumbar-Funktion durchführen und mögliche Meningitis ausschließen.
Dann würde ich eine Dermatologie anordnen und meine Therapie optimieren.
Sollte sich meine Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationärer aufnehmen.
So würde ich einen Venous-Sugang legen.
Dann würde ich Flüssigkeit, Antibiotik und Antipiratik verabreichen.
Dann würde ich die Patienten amoxicillin, Hoctozepenicillin und Doxicillin verabreichen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehenweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dieser geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Oberarzt, wie können wir Meningitis ausschließen?
Ich werde zuerst eine CT-Schadar durchführen und mögliche Hirnblutung ausschließen.
Wenn es keine Ausfälligkeit gibt, würde ich eine Lumbar-Funktion durchführen, um Meningitis ausschließen.
Dann würde ich die Patienten auf die Körperliche Untersuchung beachten, ob sie ein Kernseh- oder Brunnesseh vorlegen.
Herr Oberarzt, wie können Sie die Erisipel ausschließen?
Ich würde zuerst die Patienten auf eine kleine Lunge fragen.
Der Patient hat eine typische Eritermamigranz. Erisipel ist anders als Eritermamigranz.
Wie viel Doxicillin verabschiedet Sie?
Das ist 2x100 mg.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Welches ist das?
Das ist 2x100 mg.
Ist das richtig, Herr Oberarzt?
Ja, ich vermute es.
Okay.
2x100 mg.
7x100 mg.
Nach der Prüfung würde ich diese Nachschulagentur anbieten.
Okay. Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.
Meine Frage ist fertig.
Danke schön. Danke schön alles.
Aber wenn Sie möchten, möchte ich eine Dublexonographie aufklären.
Ja, ich würde gerne Ihnen eine Dublexonographie aufklären.
Die Dublexonographie ist eine Spezifische Ultraschallunterzuchtung mit der Via Blutgefäße Blutveränderungen.
Die Blutprobleme unter der Blut können wir unterhalten.
Die Blutprobleme unter der Blutveränderungen.
Blutgefäße veränderungen.
Die Unterzuchtung ist schmerzlos und ungefährlich.
Eine bestimmte Vorbereitung ist nicht erforderlich.
Dazu würde wir eine Gelbe auf die Haut tragen.
Die Bilder von GWB werden auf einem Monitor dargestellt.
Nach der Unterzuchtung sollte es keine Einschränkungen geben.
Der Patient kann sein Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Es wird keine Nadel und Kontrastmeter benötigt.
In manchen Fällen können andere Unterzuchtungen stattfinden.
Wir werden z.B. durch die City oder MRT durchgeführt.
Aber das abhängig vom Krankenbilder ab.
Ich bin fertig.
Hat diese Unterzuchtung Komplikationen?
Ja. Duplex-Sonographie oder?
Duplex-Sonographie.
Es gibt keine Komplikation.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Die ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja bitte.
Ich bin Anna Röhr, eine 34-jährige Patientin.
Geboren am 24.9.1990.
1,71 Meter groß.
72 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich seit 4 Tagen bestehender ringformiger Wirtung.
Im Knie links und rechts.
Erithema Migrans.
Und Fatigue.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen Fibra 37,9°.
Sie hat gegen die Wirtung bepannte Salbe.
Ich empfehle Sie eine kurze Sätze.
Ich habe eine kurze Besa.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 4 Tagen bestehender Wirtung vor.
Dann der Patient peristete das die Wirtung.
Ich empfehle.
Sie stellte sich immer besser.
Oder zäcke.
Herr Kollegen, ich empfehle Sie auch.
Jetzt Vegetative Anamnese.
Dann vorerkrankungen, Medikamente, Allergie.
Was empfehlen Sie?
Vegetative Anamnese.
Das ist die aktuelle Anamnese.
Dann Vegetative Anamnese.
Vorerkrankungen, Voroperationen, Medikamente, Allergen.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Aktuelle Anamnese nach Familienanamnese.
Aktuell ist die Anamnese beendet.
Ich fange Vegetative Anamnese.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, in der Familienanamnese...
Entschuldigung, das ist die Lymphsuche.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Fieber und Fieber in der Appetite.
Sie leidet an Diabetes mellitus Typ 1.
Die wurde mit Insulinpumpe behandelt.
Seit acht Jahren leidet sie an Migräne.
Sie wurde mit gegebenenfalls Ibuprofen und Acetylsalicylic Säure behandelt.
Bei ihr wurde wegen Inguinalherni eine Operation durchgeführt.
Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten sind keine bekannt.
Sie trinken seit zehn Jahren 15 Zigarillos täglich.
Trinken oder rauchen?
Sie rauchen seit zehn Jahren 15 Zigarillos täglich.
Sie trinken ein bis zwei Gläser Rotwein täglich.
Sie konsumieren zweimal Marihuana pro Woche.
Sie leidet alleine.
In der Familienanamnese fand sie sich bei der Schwester.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Weiseanamnese ist unaufällig.
Sie war vor fünf Tagen in Frankreich.
Sie hat gewandert.
Die Frauenanamnese ist unaufällig.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet auf Leibboreliose.
Dafür schiebt sich Erithemamigrans, Polyarthralgie, Fieber, Fatigue.
Meine Differentialdiagnostik kommt aus Erythrozypel, Prometoide, Arthritis, Meningitis.
In der Diagnostik würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die vitalen Parameter erfassen.
Anschließend würde ich die Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskültern.
Bei der Inspektion beurteile ich Erithemamigrans.
In der weiteren Erklärung würde ich die Blutuntersuchungen oder Laboruntersuchungen durchführen,
um Blutbild-CEP-PSG-Antikörper gegen Novolyose zu bestimmen.
Um eine Novolyose auszuschließen, würde ich gegebenenfalls ein CT-Shadow durchführen.
Wollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zuerst lege ich einen Venösezugang an, um Venösetherapie zu ermöglichen.
Die Therapie besteht aus zwei Teilen, der Eregabekämpfung und der symptomatischen Behandlung.
Zur Eregabekämpfung würde ich 100 mg Doxycycline zweimal täglich verabreichen.
Bei Kontraindikationen würde ich Cephoroxymaxetyl oder Penicillin verabreichen.
Bei symptomatischen Behandlungen würde ich die Fieber senken, Antipyretikum und ausreichende Flüssigkeit zuführen.
Um einen Meningitis auszuschließen, würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich auf Brutski und Kennigzeichen.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich Lumbar Funktion durchführen.
Können Sie uns die Lumbar Funktion aufklären?
Lumbar Funktion ist eine diagnostische Methode, bei der wir mit einer feinen Nadelnadelnadelnadelnadeln
die Rückenmarkflüssigkeit entnehmen.
Wir beurteilen Zellen, z.B. Lokositwerte, Glukoswerte und Eiweiß.
Die Patienten sollten sitzen und ruhig bleiben.
Wir können im Bereich der Lindenwerbelsäule zwischen L4 und L5 entnehmen.
Das ist eine Schmerzhefte Methode. Wir können Beruhigungsmittel oder Lokalanesthesie buchen.
Braucht man Vorbereitung oder empfehlen Sie nach der Untersuchung?
Das braucht nicht Vorbereitung. Nach dem Verfahren kann man normales Lindenwerf machen.
Der Patient kann sein Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Ich empfehle bei der Patientin viel Wasser trinken, um Sefalliere zu vermeiden.
Danke, Herr Oberarzt.
Wie können Sie die Erisipel ausschließen?
Bei der Inspektion können wir die Erisipel ausschließen.
Erithemamigrans ist eine ringformige Rotung.
Wir erwarten, dass es bei der Erisipel überwärmt wird.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Erisipel und Erithemamigrans?
Er ist überwärmt und hat eine rote Art.
Eine rote Rote?
Ja, bei einer Erisipel könnte es eine offene Rote sein.
Was empfehlen Sie bei der Patientin nach der Behandlung?
Nach der Behandlung empfehle ich den Patienten, wenn er wieder eine neurologische Symptome oder Arthralgie hat, eine Kontrolluntersuchung.
Regelmäßig beim Hausarzt besuchen?
Nicht regelmäßig, aber bei der Versorgung.
Impfung?
Es gibt keine Impfung gegen Leimborgeliose oder FMSE.
Aber wenn Sie im endemischen Bereich wohnen, empfehle ich Ihnen eine Impfung.
Ist diese Krankheit meldepflicht?
Ja, diese Krankheit ist meldepflicht. Wir müssen sie mitteilen.
Welche Amte melden Sie?
Landrassamt.
Gesundheitshamt?
Das ist in Landrassamten.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.